(soothing guitar music)
- Climate change is a human story.
The causes of climate change are man made
and the solutions must be man made.
How much of the landscape--
In order to reduce climate change,
in order to adapt to these changes
and to mitigate our impact on the planet,
we have to start with human stories.
I love listening to people's stories.
I'm Victoria Herrmann.
I'm a geographer and a
National Geographic explorer.
When people read stories
about climate change,
it's often in far off
places like the Arctic
or small islands,
but climate change affects everyone.
By the end of this century,
at least 420 towns, cities and villages
across the United States
will be partially underwater
no matter how much we reduce
our greenhouse gases today.
But, there's never a narrative
that should be hopeless.
There is hope in every
climate change story.
It's just about finding
the right solutions.
Over the course of 2016 and 2017,
I traveled across the United
States and U.S. Territories
and conducted over 350
interviews with local leaders
from the Chesapeake Bay to American Samoa,
from Alabama to Alaska.
At first I thought the biggest challenges
were going to be the loss of property,
the loss of houses, of
critical infrastructure,
but what people really
wanted to talk to me about
was losing histories,
the traditions that they can pass down
to the next generation.
(soothing guitar music)
I think of myself as first a listener
and then a connector.
- Oh, yes, absolutely.
Like people, a lot of people that have--
- [Victoria] Most days for me
are coming to places like here.
We are on the Eastern shore
of the Chesapeake Bay.
Geographically we're in a
place called Poverty Point
but the great organization
we're working with
has renamed it Patriot Point
to reflect the work
they're doing with this.
This is an incredible property
where vets come to hunt,
to fish, to seek the
healing that they need.
- These are the coats that we give out
to one of the service
members when they come in.
- [Victoria] The owners of Patriot Point
didn't realize that climate change
would impact them so
quickly and so intensely.
I want to understand their history,
their landscape and their
climate change challenges.
So when you see shoreline erosion,
is it usually with a big
storm that's coming in
or is it just a king tide?
- We've had a lot this year.
We're having two to three
foot above normal tides.
- [Victoria] When we
think of sea level rise
and extreme storms,
we first go to our shorelines,
to the Jersey shore with Hurricane Sandy,
or to Louisiana with Hurricane Katrina,
but climate change impacts
all bodies of water,
whether they're bays that
can see sea level rise
or rivers that can see flooding
into the plains around them.
The Chesapeake Bay is one of
the fastest changing ecosystems
in the United States
related to climate change.
At Patriot Point, I walked
along the eroding edges
to see how the land has
changed over the past year,
decade, maybe 50 years.
We're looking for trees falling over,
for tides rising above the marsh land,
to understand the rate of erosion
and how much sea levels are rising.
(soothing instrumental music)
To get a different perspective on that,
we jumped onto a boat and
saw it from the water side
so we can see how those waves
are cutting under the land,
and seeing how that is
making this whole property
more vulnerable to sea level rise.
- [Older Man] Now that was
the tidal pond right there.
- [Victoria] Oh, wow, it's all filled in.
- And we're losin' a little bit there.
- [Victoria] All local
people are valuable experts.
- Here lately we've had
these 65, 70 mile an hour
Northwest winds, Northeast winds
and there's nothin' here to stop it.
- [Victoria] The best
knowledge that we get
from any place is the people
who are living there 24/7,
and the people who are
living through those changes.
- When you got two, almost
two and a half miles
of water front, it's hard.
- Especially when that
water front is changing.
- Constantly.
(soothing instrumental music)
- [Victoria] I take everything
that I've listened to
and analyze it, think about
what potential solutions,
what other expertise we can bring in
to make that place safe.
(soothing instrumental music)
Climate change adaptations
along shore lines
often take two different forms.
Greener solutions,
which use nature to make our
landscapes more resilient,
creating salt resistant marshes,
creating areas that can
flood and bounce back,
or more gray solutions,
using concrete to build up a sea wall.
Patriot Point can benefit
from both of these.
(soothing instrumental music)
If you've grown up working
and living on the water,
not being able to live
on the Chesapeake Bay
fundamentally changes who you are,
and that's what people are afraid of.
People are afraid of
losing their identity.
- I love this area.
Born and raised here, and like I say,
this is what I truly love.
- [Victoria] How can you leave this place?
- [Older Man] That's it.
- [Victoria] Each of us has expertise
that we need to share so we
can make better solutions.
We have skills based volunteers
working all across the country,
whether it's rebuilding
a sea wall in Alaska,
helping to move a building in Louisiana,
we are helping preserve local histories
in the face of sea level rise.
The more people we have
working on a climate change solution,
the better it will be.
(soothing instrumental music)
My grandparents were Holocaust survivors.
They were survivors of
Auschwitz concentration camp
and they came to this country
with nothing but themselves
and the memories of those who were lost
and built an incredible life
and gave back to their community.
If they could find hope and
resilience in that story,
there's no reason why I
can't share that same hope
and resilience in climate
change stories today.
The future can be hopeful
if you can work together
and you can identify what every person
can contribute to a
climate change solution.
(soothing instrumental music)